difficile de passer inaperçu pour ces
deux véhicules autonomes
il embarque notamment des systèmes de
localisation de perception et de
communication avec l'extérieur c'est
renault zoé électriques ont roulé du 5
au 9 juillet dans le parc d'activités du
bel air à rambouillet une première
circulation sur route ouverte avec la
traversée de ronds-points et deux
configurations l'une classique sans
aménagement particulier l'autre avec le
giratoire de la rd 150 équipés de
caméras ces caméras filment le carrefour
détecte les usagers de la route et
transmettre leurs positions au véhicule
autonome par des modems sans fil de
communication sans fil pour prendre ses
décisions la voiture embarque un système
de navigation fonctionnant grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle l'objectif
pour les membres du laboratoire
heudiasyc qui ont mené ces
expérimentations démontrer l'interaction
entre le véhicule autonome et
l'infrastructure intelligente et
garantir un niveau de sécurité maximum
faire car véhicule autonome s'insère
dans ce genre de carrefour est
particulièrement complexe c'est vraiment
important que l'infrastructure avec ses
caméras aide le véhicule autonome a bien
percevoir à mieux anticiper ce qui se
passe et de façon à ce que sa navigation
soit soit très sûr parce que ce qu'on
veut éviter absolument quand on a un
véhicule autonome c'est qu'ils créent
des côtes des accidents qui rentrent en
collision
une semaine de test qui vient clôturer
un projet de quatre ans son nom tornado
à son initiative rambouillet territoire
qui a accueilli l'expérimentation
faciliter son déroulement
70 habitants ayant également collaboré
pour l'agglomération le défi est immense
répondre à la problématique de la
mobilité en zone rurale pour moi c'est
un vrai sujet de rayonnement du
territoire de montrer que notre
agglomération est en agglomération
innovante qui est capable de déployer du
service de très haute technologie de
très haute valeur ajoutée et c'est une
impulsion est donnée pour qu'on
poursuive un tornado 3 je l'espère de
l'appel de mes voeux dès que possible
en y candidates à ces tests ont démontré
que le véhicule autonome réagissait plus
tardivement dans des carrefours non
équipé d'infrastructures intelligentes
les ultimes conclusions seront révélées
après analyse des enregistrements
effectués lors de l'expérimentation